ah you bad [ __ ] you bad
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
you
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here direct from the Garden
of Good and Evil slinging dick given our
bubblegum it's the Lord's Day
[ __ ] if you ain't with it
you better be with it I'm just adjusting
my little [ __ ] stand over here to get
you guys nice no son I'm saying [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with uncle Joey
here direct you understand me
thinking about your mother [ __ ] as I
miss you straight from the heart it's a
beautiful day to be alive the sun's out
the birds are chirping but that don't
matter that can control what's in your
[ __ ] nutsack you understand me it's a
beautiful [ __ ] week to be alive I
know you do it's gonna snow who gives a
[ __ ] it's just another [ __ ] bump in
the road on the way to your [ __ ] goal
of death do you understand me we got
some concessional we festering with the
Platinum cookie still we have some white
rhino from perennial oh [ __ ] four 20s
around the corner and we got some
[ __ ] perennial old geezo not to fight
listen the edibles are still away know
how to boost during [ __ ] Lent so I'm
getting more strong than ever I'm ready
for you [ __ ] I'm coming to
Baltimore this week
forget about it there's gonna be twenty
inches I'm not even wearing shoes you
know saying that's how [ __ ] on fire I
am this weekend to get to Baltimore get
on [ __ ] stage it's over I've been
home for three weeks watching cartoons
you know saying being a dad but I'm
about to unleash the [ __ ] fury at
that the same way you [ __ ] got
unleash your fury it's a whole new week
March 13th whatever the [ __ ] it is
you're coming out the box like one of
those horses with steroids in them
saying you ever go to the track
to give this to horses this [ __ ]
thing it's a steroid to make him stop
bleeding from the nose but if you bet
those horses they always win why cuz
they're [ __ ] on fire that's you this
week
yeah asshole's on fire you're not taking
those [ __ ] from nobody it's over it's a
whole new [ __ ] game people these
[ __ ] don't know you control
your own destiny you understand me you
think I sat here waiting for these
people come to me none I took them to my
[ __ ] field imma stab me right or
wrong am i [ __ ] you gotta bring them
onto your field and impose your [ __ ]
will enough with your excuses and the
Trump and then the whims of [ __ ] gives a
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] Hitler is
out there giving [ __ ] rules I'd still
be doing what the [ __ ] I do he
understand me it's [ __ ] perennials on
fire today mister my balls gonna be
burning a hole through his [ __ ] thing
like Xena one of those superheroes
anyway let me tell you something enough
is enough I want that [ __ ] Facebook
yeah I woke up in all night you know I
gotta sign me just like get
[ __ ] dawg
just like you [ __ ] I got [ __ ]
on my mind I wake up in the middle of
night I go on Facebook to maybe see a
picture of a cat or somebody had a baby
and these these [ __ ] I can't
sleep the shape of the country meanwhile
these guys are [ __ ] trust-fund
[ __ ] babies that have nothing to
worry about it
but they have this unnecessary burden on
their minds this is this is the [ __ ]
that stops you this is the [ __ ] that
stops you from doing what the [ __ ] God
puts you on this planet to do all these
people in the what what do you have to
worry about all you got to worry about
is one [ __ ] that's you from
there on then you could give love to
everybody else and go to the circus and
[ __ ] and do what you got to do but it's
all about you this week that's it enough
is enough is that [ __ ] brief you were
talking about ah where's that joint you
were talking about
they're a church I'm a Dolittle riding
I'm shooting over to jujitsu with 12 get
a little rolling on the Lord's Day
nothing extreme I don't want to get
[ __ ] choked out 18 times then I'm
gonna come home write some more then we
had a podcast tonight that's it I see
the family
we haven't yslow family felt like normal
[ __ ] people I never had family
dinners on Sundays got a bunch of people
at the house playing congas and cutting
chicken heads off and [ __ ] that's not
[ __ ] family that's a party big
[ __ ] difference plate thing should we
smoke another one that's killed
let's do is white where I know this
white rhino got some kick to it give me
that song right off my Soundgarden yeah
my animes are you are you [ __ ] not so
what when you got uncle Joey sing and
that's when you know it's time to go
down anyway I don't know what you're
going through in your life I get this
every day from people you know my heart
goes to you [ __ ] but listen get
this periscope if you write down one
word from this [ __ ] periscope today
and use it I don't give a [ __ ] even if
it's I don't give a [ __ ] no more that's
it
just write that down I don't give a [ __ ]
no more it's time to be me I'm gonna
smoke dope and I'm gonna do it my way
like son or not sure that's it that's it
if you're not gonna do it your way like
Sinatra listen or shoot yourself right
now
and the [ __ ] situation go to
Starbucks and become a right-wing or
left-wing or a conservative I'm a
[ __ ] human being and my balls hang
straight to [ __ ] down the balance meat
though so I know who the [ __ ] I am in
this damn and I suggest you do the
[ __ ] same
I got a treat see you [ __ ] for
coming on periscope all right for you
people were here with uncle Joey right
now I'm gonna be on the high court
tomorrow night on Comedy Central with
[ __ ] my main man Doug Benson and then
you heard it right here before I even
shoot the ball thermometer be on the
high court tomorrow Monday and I think
so I don't know but for sure no
Wednesday I'm on the High Court to 15
see you guys get me high and then you
want me to [ __ ] him give me the fax I
can't do this [ __ ] that's a tree for you
[ __ ] because I love you you
can't keep doing this to me people you
show up you know right away you want to
[ __ ] hang and right away we got the
bottle going on and everything and then
anyway I love you [ __ ] I
appreciate everything you've done for me
you guys are savages of debt
listen I'm a loser the talent was
getting here hanging on that's it
everybody's [ __ ] funny that's all
[ __ ] everybody's fun is there's a
thousand people I look at that stage and
I go what am I gonna get that [ __ ]
funny and I'm saying it's all about
balls people everything else black
background [ __ ] music
smoke your reefer write your goals leave
your 22 pushes for the soldiers and
everything works out you don't believe
me ask Li saya just by putting write it
up paper put it in your mind see what
pops up I'm saying what do you think one
more just for what do you do what do you
get the bonus I thought to Grandma but I
say I had old geezer [ __ ] I got a butter
perennial inside I had this little
portable heater I get my weed mat put in
front of the heat it's all over after
that I've burned that [ __ ] down to the
to the buddy's [ __ ] brittle you
understand me
this is why my balls on fire these
things don't tap the eyes look like this
Mallika Nadia Puma a bicycie horny oh
yeah you know say I don't know what I'm
gonna do boy
wait on a paint any your so I copied
under both dryer
oh you guys would never believe I'm an
only child I don't need to hang out with
people to show you this my time with you
people on this little [ __ ] tank is
tremendous
this is my [ __ ] therapy so thank you
I get up in the morning I'm ready to
stab a [ __ ] you don't be dog
I got [ __ ] inside minutes ready to
[ __ ] blow up I love you [ __ ]
thank you for listening
grab a pen or smoke some reefer give
your wife a stab and shoot the goat do
whatever the [ __ ] you need to do it's
the Lord's dead [ __ ] have a great day
see you tonight
seven o'clock stay black have a great
day and I love you [ __ ] lawyer
bull ah pain yelling throw out higher